[Music]
this is Resident Evil extinction which
as you don't recall is the third
Resident Evil movie also there's
supposed to fool you into thinking it's
the first movies first scene all over
again
and I must admit the doctors who created
this reality did a good job from putting
the shower curtain in the exact same
position to getting Alice to react the
exact same way she did the first movie
remarkable oh sorry just here to get
some milk you know how we know we're
deep into a franchise at this point they
start playing The Greatest Hits record
Alice jumps over the thing that can
easily be ducked under I'm sort of at a
loss as to why the security system
doesn't just lead with the unfair laser
configuration arbitrarily placed Indiana
Jones booby traps and the simulation is
a dick but honestly Alice pulls a rookie
move by being surprised by a gun-toting
drone that came out of the floor after
tripping a totally concealed trigger
mechanism simple and off my helmet that
I obviously need for some reason so that
you can see I'm the bad guy from the end
of the last movie they just shot of the
blood they never do that what does this
experiment trying to prove that she
should be able to dodge booby traps
it feels more like dragon's lair than
Resident Evil also as we're about to
find out this is an ALICE clone one of
many they have already thrown into a
ditch after some sort of failure so why
does even need to instruct these guys to
do what they have already done many
times before cool secret door
my question is where is the moving floor
going in this enclosed space
Alice landfill also there's no telling
how much decomposition there should be
after this many Alice deaths but aside
from all the blood all of these Alice's
are camera-ready also also it seems like
every Alice got killed by the killer
drone with bullets not one of these
Alice's got killed by the Laser grid or
they out of nowhere Indiana Jones blade
also also also this place takes great
pains and having a secret facility deep
underground complete with a secret
elevator but they leave clone corpses in
a ditch a mere 20 feet away nobody won't
ask any questions if they see that
yeah whatever here's your sag card dick
umbrella corporation thought they'd
contained the infection the infection in
this case being movie narration virus
came to swipe out human life lakes and
rivers dried up forest became desert
yeah why why does the virus have the
power to do that sounds a lot like scar
taking over the pride lands unnecessary
ground-level helicopter shot to show the
lonely vehicle driving across a desert
cliche KL cape
pupil Perry I guess the t-virus wiped
out all of humanity and dried out rivers
and made forests into deserts but
somehow there are still people living
despite the catastrophic change to the
eco system we will only reveal ourselves
once you find out the baby is fake that
makes for a more satisfying robbery
which is gigantic all bad guys are
rapists Sloane's down here suggest these
bandits have thrown people down this pit
before but who's responsible for getting
the demon dogs back in their cages they
can't shoot these things with
tranquilizer darts can they or do they
just get Chris Pratt to use one of this
clicker things like he did in Jurassic
world you don't know what's going on in
the scene I don't know what's going on
in this scene so who gives it if one of
these movies could focus on something
for longer than a tenth of a second it
would be almost masterful to this genre
everything lines up way too neatly for
Alice to get out of the rancor pit
considering the heaps of randomness that
just happened and how many cups does it
take to show someone running straight up
a ramp anyway zombie didn't hear a
convoy of assholes driving down this
lone road until two seconds to impact
also even though I have no real reason
to believe this I highly doubt whatever
scenario led to this poor bastard on the
road getting eaten it's probably because
he looks way too good to be a former
survivor of the apocalypse just lowly is
made up of 55% helicopter shots of
people driving down desert roads hey
Carlos Claire okay they're ready how can
I help you
haha sorry campers character
introduction through radio conversation
using antibodies from her blood I will
develop a serum that will not just
combat the effects of the t-virus but
potentially reverse and that's why I
have been cloning Alice and sending her
into death mazes to reverse the effects
of the t-virus somehow I'll never be
human it would provide the basis for a
dose of work force my guess is the
umbrella elite would not like to have a
guy with several bullet wounds and
chunks removed from his leg serving them
tea and there's a very high chance of
something going wrong under the system
but yeah let's rehabilitate the zombies
sounds like an awesome idea without the
original project Tyler's progress is
being difficult and I recall you let her
go at the end of the last movie when you
could have simply recaptured her after
her escape we will never get an
explanation as to why you did that
either simply the modeling results will
not guarantee
perhaps we should play someone else in
charge someone who can give us the
reassurances we require so you'd rather
have the guy who tells you yep we are
going to 100% succeed at turning zombies
into slaves don't worry about it and
then fails time and again also the dream
the part where they said most of
humanity it died is Wesker going to find
someone with the scientific credentials
dr. Isaacs possesses feels like an empty
threat
germn so why don't you call a meeting
in a boardroom if you're just going to
be there in hologram form is it the only
place equipped for hologram meeting none
of these movies ever bother to explain
the hologram dynamic I want to know how
these guys sitting in completely
different places in the world managed to
angle themselves perfectly for a
boardroom meeting like this if I'm
sitting one way at home how does that
translate to me sitting at a different
angle in hologram form how do I track
someone like dr. Isaacs as he walks
around the room and how does this
simulation thing we saw before the scene
began - tech hologram figures
apparently a badly decomposed body is in
here hence all the Flies but wouldn't
there be a tremendous fly presence
outside to do as well like they all
decided to conduct their fly business
and brevet in case you were wondering
Claire Redfield and her crew are still
driving down the road for sure to get
many glamor shots of it enjoy she's
quiet
yeah gaunt a hallway looking like both
of these characters who were in the last
movie probably already know that quiet
doesn't equal safe but that dialogue is
for you dumbass audience so 55% of this
movie is helicopter shots of people
driving another 60 percent of it is
people walking slowly into a strange
place with their guns drawn I'm not sure
what the other 23% of this movie is yet
but when I get results back from the lab
I'll let everyone know man if zombies
could just learn not to ground their
presence during another wise quiet
approach they'd have a better success
rate they telling me this mirror is so
clean that he didn't realize it is a
reflection also why are there zombies
just walking around in the dark hoping
humans will one day show up they
apparently crave you in the flesh but
decide to hang out in these places just
to be scary dicks zombie somehow bit
through LJ's shirt but did not tear it
and it didn't bleed through sombody me
the umbilical abrasion make sure to use
only Sony products while conducting
their company business this is
incredible serum works
you've domesticated them I can say this
with confidence after seeing the zombie
perform three successful tasks in one
sitting
Klingon mushroom be damned how do you do
that it's one of my skills dyeing yarn
unfortunately shaking hands with no
labels on them and figuring out what
they contain as a dying art was it ever
an art is this something cavemen were
able to do maybe he's joking but that
doesn't look like he's joking
kind of fruit this guy's been telling
people with absolute certainty what's in
these cans asparagus cream of mushroom
soup pork and beans but when it comes to
this one can all he can say is I think
that's some kind of fruit also a lot of
these cans not have labels that'll about
when the zombie apocalypse occur
food removing their labels in syrup I
want a menorah and be sure to use a
gas-powered vehicle when you do it we
have unlimited fuel around here still
don't know how they're able to run high
tech like this without the world's
infrastructure and very little fuel and
I'm very certain they aren't running
this stuff on batteries lamp scared you
know what they don't have to see the
computer simulation of us going
underground anymore we get it already
Alice dreams of Resident Evil apocalypse
a nurse wait does that mean she's
wouldn't have detected a peek inside on
a cactus tree because when umbrella
built me they made sure that I could
detect psychic powers those being so
common in old master psionic activity
was detected 15 minutes ago it took 15
minutes for us to tell you because we
had to run it through our Miss Cleo
database to make sure wasn't whales
humping or some seismic anomaly as an
evil movie turns into Birdemic
or the birds I really prefer the suckier
movie though when I'm describing sucking
up this entire swarm of bloodthirsty
birds are all flying around the camps
but they don't sweep down in masses
until these guys States before the bus I
say the effects are almost on par with
Birdemic as well maybe the moral is
don't do a movie with killer Birds
I guess telekinesis allows you to turn a
flamethrower which has absolute limits
on the amount of flame it can expel and
turn it into a giant flaming cloud of
death 45 percent probability that this
is full jackass
I would calculate more probability but
the odds that she just happens to be
near an umbrella facility where you work
is so astronomical my microchips nearly
fried and disbelief
parasitic HEV I've grown as a geometric
rate into a skate from the detour to the
location this makes her appearance in
this part of the country at the same
time you are here even more ridiculous
it made such a big deal about number 87
and now she's dead we took the time to
trump up her qualifications okay Kmart
that's where they found me to having
over news never liked it
everyone I know is dead in like hundred
change yeah to Kmart I'm sure that's
much better than whatever name you had
before you're tracking me I couldn't be
around you it yeah wasn't it a lot more
than just tracking you basically went to
an unconscious state at the end of the
last movie like they had control over
you also if they could track you then
why the hell were they unsuccessful in
bringing you in I mean you're badass but
not that badass I'm still trying to
figure out why dr. Isaacs let you go
when he could have just recaptured you
in the first place Hey
what time is it Carlos it is a 12/14 y
yeah somewhere you gotta be
you're the asshole wearing the watch
asshole time doesn't matter anymore then
stop being such a poser and throw that
watch away basic transmission say but
there's no inspection up there it's
isolated but it's also Alaska so you can
see the pine work okay right unnecessary
hope I've got half a tank again that's
it okay yeah did I don't have happy
enough for a hundred miles
Dom so less than empty and can still
drive a hundred miles but pretty awesome
actually
hey get me that it's not a Vegas joke
like if it were Seattle that'd be
Seattle sounds good to me or if the
Nashville would be Nashville is music to
my ears or it will Vancouver be
Vancouver will be riot committee
authorizes immediate action release of
vehicles and personnel dr. Isaacs has
obviously seen sneakers but who was this
message for was it for the computers or
is it for the employees because anyone
actually hearing this message should
know this sounds cut and paste it and
fake and all truthfulness the computer
should know that - this isn't 1992 this
is what every year this is also once the
order is given doesn't wesker
immediately find out and say well I
didn't get that order and then
immediately fire dr. Isaacs for voice
forgery luckily there is not only a
Vegas sign right here telling them it's
only 89 miles away but that's the
maximum amount of miles any of these
vehicles can drive got another question
how did this person who hanged him or
herself know about the wonders of
post-apocalyptic Alaska how did they get
these pictures and if so why didn't they
just stay there or are these pictures
cut out of magazines to get them visual
aids of what it might be like even when
the apocalypse happens in Vegas
filmmakers can't resist showing you the
Statue of Liberty in shambles
even when it's just a garish Vegas
replica we're gonna have to move it or
go around maybe or walk to wherever the
gas station is you plan to siphon gas
from also once they remove this crate
doesn't look like there's no way they
could go through this tunnel you can't
see any zombies right now but once they
start running out it's like a clown car
amount of zombies that couldn't possibly
have fit without at least a few of them
being visible also this seems like an
opportune time for Alice to use your
psychic power to close the crate again
or throw the crate into the Sun or make
the zombies spontaneously combust
something it's like at hours when you
can just turn the movie into a shooting
gallery I guess what I don't need to be
an asshole about this every time it
happens but we have no clue where
everyone is there isn't one wide shot of
the playing field the series of edits of
zombies running people running people
shooting guns and quick flashes of
zombies getting killed there was no
reason why this action scene can't be
more coherent
it's not like you're filming superheroes
here just people with gun shooting it
zombies not intense in view underworld I
mean Resident Evil also considering the
chaos that the editing suggests everyone
should be dead by the end of the scene
there's no way to survive this despite
the fact that the zombies were running
out of a crate and we're in a bottleneck
type of situation many of the managed to
avoid all the bullets split up and run
all over Vegas to attack Claire's convoy
I guess Carlos also heard the music died
down and got a false sense of security
from he suddenly turns into the House of
the Dead video game and I guess a little
bit of a movie - then shut her down see
this is what I'm talking about this is
what happened at the end of apocalypse
so how did she wrest control away from
dr. Isaacs in the first place later the
movie will show Alice resisting the
control but that's never explained is
the reason why she was able to break it
the first time and nobody in umbrellas
seems to have a cool about what happened
before either please don't go to space
and show us the Scott damnit ah
apparently zombies were engaged with a
human being and we're about to eat them
are easily distracted by exclamations
but in the conditioner push the control
chain because we an umbrella believe
that we should use the minimal amount of
control signal until you really need
that extra power Alice is walking
straight for dr. eyes extent all he
needs is her blood so why aren't they
exiting the tent guns blazing instead
they try to control her again which as
this movie established a couple minutes
ago can't be done or at the very least
is too risky
why don't you after hang back luckily
nearly the entire convoy died so that a
helicopter is now practical also the
plan is to steal the helicopter which is
flying to the umbrella compound which is
surrounded by zombies rather than make
the drive which seems way safer Alice
would rather risk everyone's life trying
to get the remaining crew on the
helicopter
technical board also I wouldn't live too
much about dr. Izak condition he's going
to find a cure in season seven good
thing I like a challenge or you can just
use your psychic powers seems like
something I'm thinking a lot same thing
mouki pretends we really care about this
Allyson Carlos relationship which came
out of nowhere in the last movie and
it's given no real extra weight in this
one just kill the zombies already
sweetie makes it seem late
thank god this guy was going to die
anyway so he can sacrifice himself to
blow up all the zombies but it feels
like they could have just taken this rig
and moved along with it and they would
have solved the problem pretty easily
while this explosion is impressive and
everything it doesn't well it merely is
the amount of zombies this movie wants
you to believe even in this shot but
when alice is ready to hit the gas the
zombies are cleared out completely it's
a good thing they don't show us how many
kids are still alive because I have
serious doubts that they can all fit in
this helicopter anyway I don't doubt
Clara can fly on Lookout they're just
that the movie has never made that
skillet Alice steps on the floorboard
and the secret elevator shaft magically
opens for feels like if you were
creating a secret elevator it wouldn't
be just easy to expose and how did she
make the elevator come up to her so that
she could go back down there wasn't a
control panel in sight I think the movie
was hoping you wouldn't ask questions
about the elevator but back in 2007 we
didn't exist yet
geez as it's only had to kill like two
people why did he go all Tommy was so in
a lab after that your sister she was a
homicidal bitch why does the artificial
intelligence even need a sister is it
because the first actress grew up and
they still needed a little british girl
to give exposition your blood has bonded
with the t-virus doc guy has correctly
deduced that it could be used to destroy
the biohazard for good it'll take at
least three movies for that to happen oh
and this facility contains all the
equipment you will require to synthesize
actual well it didn't kill Isaac's
destroyed everything in the lab I can
handle that it'll give you a great
excuse to pull out your gun and walk
slowly through the building again also
why are you in the monitor now why can't
you just be standing next to her the
hologram in this hallway
go back some help they trapped me inside
this computer make me pretend to be
artificial intelligence I need you to
find a hacker named hua I had a chance
to kill you right here
but I shall pass by in a frightening
fashion know what passes by like I do
cower in fear at my passing at least
alice's clone was modest during her
short life also a movie really misses an
opportunity to have to Alice's kicking
ass in this movie's final battle that
might have been cool to see even though
I'm sure the special effects would have
been terrible indicated to think Alice
should never pick up a photograph again
and especially enough this one approch
am what it gives all the monsters in
this movie a chance to sneak up behind
her crazy this floor has such shoddy
workmanship that Alice can stomp the
floorboard and catapult this knife into
the air oh yeah my psychic powers that I
will only use in the final battle this
one witch died immediately after being
released from her embryonic sac or
whatever the is no alive for some reason
either that or she's auditioning to be
body number 1 in audition to the
auditioning should you slice them you
psychic powered him through a wall but
let's see if kicking and punching works
Alice clone ex machina also how did
clone Alice even know to get up go to
the computer and stop the killer laser
in the first place how does she know
what keys to press and now that the
laser is stopped why is she still
pressing Keys all data will be
transferred to this facility expect
results within one lock because I expect
science to be magic I built one of those
baking soda volcanoes once and if that's
anything like genetic engineering we
should be able to finish the project
over a weekend with my dad lasers will
continue under my personal supervision
you won't have to wait that long boy
good at the conference room to have an
extra chair ready for any asshole who
might want to tap into this hologram
meeting also I don't know how she knew a
meeting was taking place or how she
heard everything leading up to her
one-liner but would someone explain this
hologram meeting thing to me again god
damn it I have so many questions
he saw attack of the clones and said
Miku
now you're looking for the secret but
you buy one for the course you're not
really looking
you don't live to work
you want to be my name is Mac my world
is fire and blood seems quiet too quiet
I wanted a what a lovely day multipad
your parrot a play